i don't know if maybe there's a contest
going on between republican senators
who can appear to be the most
disconnected from the modern world
and how we talk about things in 2021 but
if such a contest
exists i would nominate republican
senator
john kennedy no relation to the
democratic
kennedy family in the last month i
brought you the story of senator john
kennedy
strangely trying to equate guns and cars
as well as kind of equating the
regulation of guns and cars you can
check out that segment
from the march 24th show if it sounds
interesting and it is actually pretty
interesting
but yesterday john kennedy was on fox
news ostensibly talking
about i guess police shootings and
police brutality
and he started talking about how we
quote higher
whites blacks and browns
it was as strange a segment as it sounds
let's take a look
there's no justice we can't have a
society without order
and we have decided to hire law
enforcement officials to maintain order
we hire whites blacks browns
men women to maintain
order many many of our of our
law enforcement agencies are are
majority monarch
if you want to sound like a racist
southerner like if you really want to
play the prototypical caricature
of a racist american right-wing
southerner
you say exactly what he said in exactly
that
accent exactly how he talks about whites
blacks and browns that's how you make
yourself look like
the typical uh caricature of a southern
racist american in another moment
from the same appearance senator kennedy
apparently in an effort to push back
against the defund the police movement
which is supported by
very few people he says if you don't
like police next time call a crackhead
that's his word not mine i'll put it
this way if you hate cops just because
they're cops you don't know anything
about them
then next time you get in trouble call a
crackhead
now having said that
what we're really talking about here
what we're talking about here is the
relationship
between crime and race
let's just cut to the chase it is a
statistical fact
that just as it is the case that more
men
than women commit crimes just as it is a
statistical fact
that more younger people than older
people commit crimes
we have racial minorities and ethnic
groups in america that have higher crime
rates
we have to why poverty
but that doesn't tell you anything that
is a sitting
united states senator if you can believe
it this
opens up the possibility of so many
skits and satire on saturday night live
that they must be thanking the comedy
gods right now
if you don't like police call a
crackhead
next time you're in trouble why not just
improve policing
and then feel better about calling the
police most people don't want to
actually defund or abolish the police
why do you need to go to what we have
or crack heads it's a very strange
kind of backwards reverse
rationalization
the choices are police we don't believe
are as well trained as they should be
and drug addicts like how are those the
parameters that we should be selecting
between
and by the way when i was preparing this
segment
i got a phone call and the clip kept
playing without sound
if you want to see a really a scary
movie so to speak
watch senator uh john kennedy speaking
without the audio on it's really the
stuff of nightmares but that's an aside
now there's like one percent
that john kennedy gets correct here
don't hate police for
being police most police officers
are people who are choosing to be police
officers
for admirable good reasons and who never
have complaints
against them about use of force it would
be bad
it would be a non-thinking reason
to hate an individual officer because
they are
a police officer at the same time and
this is where you know it's almost like
they can't hold
two ideas simultaneously at the same
time
you can understand that all
officers can be part of a system
that is not productively serving
a large portion of the people in their
respective communities and that
there are changes there that need to be
made none of it involves
crackheads none of it involves drug
addicts
of any kind now i know that the
caricature is
the left just wants to end police or
defund the police or cancel police or
whatever there are some who want to do
that
most don't but we have the public uh
polling data
on it what most people want is to reform
and restructure the police and i know
that there are some on the left
including in my audience who get mad and
they say
reform has never worked why would it
work now well we've not actually done it
and there are police unions that get in
the way of certain reform
elements that are often recommended and
suggested including a national bad
actors database
that police departments be mandated to
both report to the bad actors database
as well as
um uh to use it for
reference when hiring a new police
officer
i have multiple segments with 10 or 12
possible specific reforms
most people just want to improve
policing there are situations
where you don't need an armed officer to
show up there are situations that are
better de-escalated
by social workers and others but we
could also give police officers better
training as social workers that's
another great idea
better equip them for de-escalation in
many countries police are much better
trained
for de-escalation none of it requires
crack heads and none of it requires
defunding or canceling the police